>>presenter: And today I have the honor to
be seeing of introducing our speaker, who
along with being an accomplished business
leader, an author, happened to be my uncle,
and a darned good one at that.
[laughter]
Jack is here today to speak about his book,
"Lessons on Leadership", which he wrote in
order to help pass on leadership skills that
he learned during his career at Coca-Cola
and Revlon.
Jack started his career at Coca-Cola in 1979.
He represented the company to Wall Street
and led the team responsible for planning
and acquisitions.
At just 36, Jack became CFO of the company.
He had become responsible for all financial
strategies as a Coca-Cola employee.
Jack moved on to become president and COO
of Coca-Cola worldwide and served in this
position until 2001.
Next, Jack took the position of president
and CEO of Revlon, where he was able to use
his key understanding of branding and his
relationship to consumers to improve market
share, reduce debt, and position the company
for continued profitability.
Jack currently serves on many boards, including
Dr. Pepper Snapple Group, The Boys & Girls
Clubs of America, and The United Negro College
Fund.
Jack's book, "Lessons on Leadership: The 7
Fundamental Management Skills for Leaders
at All Levels", was published in 2007 and
will be the basis for his talk today.
I think the eighth published skill may have
been knowing when to shut up. So, I'm gonna
go ahead and pass it on to Jack.
[applause]
>>Jack Stahl: Thank you all very much. It's
my honor to be here today.
I'm humbled in thinking about the fact that,
while I was at Coca-Cola for over 20 years,
and I thought of Coca-Cola as a very big,
very global company, I realized it took Coca-Cola
120 years to be a 20 billion dollar company
-- something that your company did in only
nine years.
So, that's quite an amazing achievement and
I suspect the parallel between the two companies
is inside of each, there are some great leaders
at all levels of both companies.
And what I'd like to do today is, perhaps,
provide a framework for thinking about leadership.
Whether or not you manage people, it doesn't
really matter.
Some of you might manage projects, you might
manage functions, you might manage a portion
of a project, or a customer relationship,
and I think leadership skills, in a framework
for thinking about leadership applies across
all of those ways of doing business.
So, that's what I'd like to share with you
today. And
[pause]
to do that, let me ask a question. And I'm
just gonna take a quick poll.
How many of you would think that, as you think
about leaders that you know that are effective,
maybe it's your boss or a peer, it might have
been a parent or friend, how many of you would
say that leadership is something that you're
born with, it’s an attribute that you inherited
in some fashion, versus a skill that can be
learned?
I'm curious to how you would think about that.
How many of you think of leaders as being
born and have those skills?
OK. And those of you who think of it as a
set of skills that can be learned over a period
of time?
Well, I can go home. This is a very easy talk
at this moment.
[laughter]
Normally, people tend to think of leadership
as something that is born or inherited.
I happen to believe, based on working with
people for over 30 years, that you can think
of leadership as a flow of very concrete actions
that over time, can help you lead effectively
and move an organization, or a function, or
a relationship, in a positive direction.
And if you do those series of actions well,
when things get crazy, you can be the emotional
touchstone. You can be the center for what
your organization, or your function, is trying
to do.
So, I'm gonna walk you through just one framework
that I have found has been useful to me over
a long period of time. And that framework
starts with setting a compelling destination
for your organization, developing a strategy
and a plan, a lot of emphasis on communication,
a focus on management routines, which are
important in getting things done in a project
environment, or in any role; execution, being
visible for your people and then developing
the organization that you are responsible
for.
And I'm gonna try to provide some anecdotes
from Coca-Cola and from Revlon.
Now remember, when you hear my Coca-Cola stories,
this is from the company and the person that
was very involved in developing New Coke about
20 years ago, which was probably the biggest
new product disaster in the history of mankind.
So, everything I say, you're gonna have to
take with a slight grain of salt.
But there are some learnings, even in that.
So, this is the framework that I'm gonna walk
through.
And I'll start with setting a compelling destination
for your organization.
I was interested to read, when I did a Google
search on Google, about your destination,
which was set out by your founders of organizing
and making useful and accessible the world's
information. And I can think about working
here and having that being something that
would pull me in a positive direction towards
trying to make a contribution to the growth
of the company.
And I think in so many worlds, whether it's
a religious environment, or a business environment,
people want something bigger to point to.
And I'll give you some examples of my own
past.
At Coca-Cola, we were looking for a way--
mind you, Coca-Cola had a very strong market
share position, like a 45 percent share of
market, as Google has a strong position today--
but we wanted to move that up dramatically.
And, at one point in the mid-90s, we set a
destination for creating what we called a
360 degree Coca-Cola landscape.
To some of you, that sounds a little bit bold
and audacious; maybe a little bit obnoxious.
But if you're in the beverage business and
you're trying to grow it, the notion was having
Coca-Cola be available within an arm's reach
of desire, having the brand be preferred by
consumers all around the world, and having
the price and value of the product be right
in consumer's minds, whether you were in New
York City or in Beijing.
The price and value had to be right and had
to be affordable. So, setting a 360 degree
Coca-Cola landscape became the goal, became
the objective of our business in the United
States.
And I would suggest to you that in any role,
or any function, managing a project, managing
a customer relationship, to the extent that
you can set a goal, a destination that means
something to the people that you're working
with; you'll get there that much faster.
I was amazed when we set this destination.
We actually had a little mural done, -it was
kind of corny at the time, a little painting
that actually pictured a Coca-Cola landscape,
with people and teenagers walking around with
various Coca-Cola products and Coca-Cola was
an important part of the community, doing
the right thing around the world.
And it was amazing how many people had this
up in their offices as a way of reminding
them where the company was going. So, an important
part.
At Revlon, which was a bankrupt company when
I got there about eight years ago, we set
a destination that was meant to be compelling,
which was delivering the promise of beauty.
And beauty, to our customers, to women, means
so many different things, both physical and
emotional.
And the promise of beauty meant delivering
profits to our retail customers, whether it
be drug stores, or Wal-Mart, or whoever sold
cosmetics, and to our shareowners.
So, this was our destination that we set for
ourselves in the beauty business.
And again, it's amazing how people rallied
around setting a destination which they found
compelling.
So, I think the first building block for strong
leadership in any function is to think about
how you set that for the activities that you're
part of in the organization, that you're part
of or leading.
[pause]
I'm curious. In the roles that you play, how
many of you are actually managing people versus
performing a function, or managing, say, a
customer relationship? Do many of you have
actually people management responsibilities?
OK. And to any of you, have any of you had
experience, or have you experimented with
setting a destination for your own functions
or organizations that meant something to you.
Is that something you've done? I'm just curious.
>>audience #1: Sure. Yes.
>>Jack Stahl: OK. What's your function?
>>audience #1: I'm an account executive working
with customers and inside teams…
>>Jack Stahl: Okay.
>>audience #1: driving against a main objective
across [inaudible] trying to focus on…
>>Jack Stahl: Okay.
>>audience #1: how much of a [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: OK.
So, having a destination and then quantifying
it makes it more real for your team and, very
good.
Any other experiences in setting destinations
that have been useful to anybody? I'm curious
about your own experiences. Yes.
>>audience #2: We have [inaudible] and share
our personal objectives.
>>Jack Stahl: OK.
>>audience #2: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Great. Beautiful. Good.
I think those can be very powerful.
The next question, OK, once you've got a destination,
great leaders always are very thoughtful about
the pathways, the strategies in other words,
to get there.
And I'm gonna use a very historical example,
and that's Ford Motor Company. Henry Ford
invented the automobile for all intents and
purposes. He mass-produced it and his strategy
was to make the automobile affordable. And
that's how he thought he could grow the industry.
And the way he got there was mass production.
That became an important, strategic tool for
him. And the old saying went, "You can have
any color Ford you want as long as it's black."
[laughter]
And he got people with an affordable car;
it built the industry, and the rest is history.
But he was very strategic about using mass
production as a way of building his particular
industry. And I think setting strategies,
or pathways, are important for any leader
in any function.
So, the beauty of a clear strategy is everybody
in your organization can understand it, they
can get their arms around it and it allows
them to prioritize; it allows them to stop
doing stuff that isn't on the strategy. And
I would ask you, as leaders, are you being
clear enough about what the strategies, or
the pathways, are that you want to follow
for your area of responsibility? Yes.
>>audience #3: How do you galvanize people
[inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: When I use the word "galvanize"
there, and I'll go back to the Coca-Cola example,
we had set a destination of a 360 degree Coca-Cola
landscape. We had three key strategies for
getting there and it was so simple. It was
the three "A's". Affordability of the product,
acceptability of the product--meaning the
brand was loved-- and availability of the
product, which meant we wanted the product
within arm's reach of desire.
So, those three "A's", affordability, acceptability,
and availability. If an action wasn't tied
to one of those three A's, then you were expected
to deprioritize it. So, all the energy was
pointed in those directions.
>>audience #3: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Galvanize is -- you could think
about it as focus. That's my way of saying
focus, I guess.
Does the word mean something different to
you in that context? Did it trigger something
for you? What was in your head? I'm curious.
>>audience #3: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Ah. Are you a scientist?
>>audience #3: Most of us are.
>>Jack Stahl: OK. Well, let's use your word.
What's your name?
>>audience #3: Alexander.
>>Jack Stahl: Alexander's point was galvanize
is, in scientific work-- terms, the attraction
of chemicals to--
>>audience #3: An electrode.
>>Jack Stahl: An electrode. And this is attracting
people's energy to a set of focus priorities.
So it is, I think, very similar. Thank you
for that.
But then the question becomes, are you, as
leaders, making those tough choices?
When I got to Revlon, the company was basically
broken and bankrupt. There was a lot of money
to be made serving men, with men's products.
People believed that men's cosmetics was gonna
be the next great thing.
We had to get it right with women first or
we were not gonna be able to pay the bills.
Or, somebody here said "we're not gonna be
able to afford the cookies." We had to get
it right by focusing on men and galvanizing
energy around focusing on women.
Any other questions or comments on this? Yes.
>>audience #4: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Could you say that just a little
bit louder?
>>audience #4: How much of what you have said
assumes that the person who has good quality
strategy has a position of authority in the
organization versus [inaudible] without necessarily
having a position of authority?
>>Jack Stahl: Yeah. I think both models work.
I tend to think of this as situations where
you have ownership for some level of work
or activity, without necessarily positional
authority.
So, for example, if you're on a customer team
and you've got a customer relationship that
is a ten million dollar business today, you
believe it can be a 20 million dollar business
and you go about setting pathways to get there;
that's not necessarily positional authority
and you may have coworkers that can help deliver
against that 20 million dollar goal, but I
don't think it requires positional authority.
I think it requires ownership of an activity
more than positional authority. Does that
address your question?
So, I do think it's broader than a traditional
hierarchy.
[pause]
Any other comments or questions, thoughts
or reactions, here? OK.
And then, with a strategy in mind, what about
quantifying it? I'm sometimes embarrassed
to talk about this number, but I will anyway.
[laughter]
When I was asked to run the North American
business, and this was in the mid-90s at Coca-Cola,
people were actually drinking 400 drinks per
person per year of Coca-Cola products.
And I can see the reactions in terms of health
and wellness and the concerns. And those are
very fair and we did react to that and I'll
talk about that in a moment.
But we were in the business of selling beverages.
And we thought to ourselves, "If it's 400
today, where can it be in the future?" We
did some analytics and we found out that it
was 400 overall, but believe it or not, it
was 750 in certain parts of southern Mississippi.
And it was 675 in North Dakota, believe it
or not.
So we started asking ourselves the question,
"If it's 400 on average, but there are places
where it's much higher, there must be places
where it's much lower, like Southern California
for one reason or another. If we can get the
75 up to 300, and the 300 up to 550, then
overall, let's set a target of 600 drinks
per person."
And the organization looked at us like we
were crazy. There had been about 50 of us
who had developed this goal, but once we had
set that goal, we went about setting the clear
strategies and tactics to get us there and
it required us to introduce juices and healthier
products and waters and teas and ready-to-drink
coffees, and a whole host of vitamin enriched
products.
And sure enough, seven years later, we didn't
make the 600, but we made 550 up from 400.
And only by setting a very aggressive target,
did it force a different set of conversations
amongst our team about how to get there.
It took more vending machines; it took a wider
range of products, mostly healthier products
than carbonated soft drinks.
And I would ask you as leaders, are you setting
objectives that are stretched and aggressive
enough to force a different set of thinking,
different questioning of assumptions that
can help propel your organization, or your
function, forward?
And I think it's critical to creating growth
and value.
Any questions or comments on this one, because
oftentimes this creates a little bit of angst
about the idea of over-pushing an organization
or a group of people and it can create a fair
number of questions sometimes. You're a salesperson.
Typically, it's the salesperson who jumps
at me at this point.
[laughter]
>>audience #5: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: OK, fair enough.
>>Jack Stahl: We had to think outside the
box, exactly. Yes.
>>audience #6: Will the sales of the [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Yeah. Alexander's question was,
and underneath it really, maybe would you
be better off targeting 550 and achieving
550, than setting such a stretch goal?
For me, it was never – it was never -- if
we'd set it at 1300, or 1100, or even 900,
it wouldn't have seemed credible, but something
that was big enough to create a different
dialogue, a different conversation.
Go ahead.
>>audience #5: In other words, if you had
set 650, you would have achieved 600?
>>Jack Stahl: Oh, I think we probably maxed
it out, but I think my fear when setting objectives
is if you don't set them aggressively enough,
you don't force different enough conversations.
And people will go about with their same patterns
of growing the business, or dealing with customers,
or thinking about how they develop code.
Only by setting a more aggressive target,
can you help force people's thinking into
different pathways. So that's why I think
the numbers are so important. Yes.
>>audience #6: So different organizations
look at stretched goals differently. People
get nervous about it
[inaudible] trust ourselves. Another looks
at it as a challenge and something to strive
for.
>>Jack Stahl: Right.
>>audience #6: So is there anything else [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Right. Well, I think to get
to 600, we had to say to the organization,
"We're willing to invest another 500 million
dollars in vending machines," for example.
We had to say that we were willing to build
up our new product development department
dramatically. So they knew that Coca-Cola
was willing to invest behind that goal.
And the other thing we did was, we said, "Look,
we're gonna set our compensation systems up
in a way where if you get to 550 over a six
or seven year period of time, you're gonna
be rewarded for that. You're not gonna get
hit on the head for falling short of what
seemed like a very aggressive goal."
So I think it's a combination of resources
and how you set the compensation systems that
were important. Does that address your question?
>>audience #6: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: OK. I'm gonna speak to that
directly in just a few minutes, but it did
start with the strategies that got us here.
I got input from probably 6000 people as a
leader. I travelled to every location in the
United States. I was on every shop floor,
as an example. I met with every salesperson
in one form or another and it was, literally,
a two-way dialogue that shaped the strategies
to get there.
So, it did start with that.
Yes.
>>audience #7: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Yeah. The question was, how
did we decide, at Coca-Cola, to go from carbonated
soft drinks into a newer product like water?
It was grounded in consumer research. People,
even 15 years ago, were increasingly calorie
conscious. They were increasingly aware of
ingredients that were listed on the package.
We can see trends in other parts of the world.
We spent a lot of time, for example, in the
Japanese soft drink market. If the US had
this much variety, the Japanese market had
15 times the amount of variety.
And we began to see the consumer wanting more
products on the shelves and in-and-out products
and more excitement.
And it told us to we had to extend the product
line and water seemed like, from a research
standpoint, the biggest market segment that
was first available to us.
Yes.
>>audience #8: As a publically traded company,
how do you balance that stretched goal and
if it's out there in the world and you over-hit
by 50, all the analysts say you failed and
your stocks go through the floor? How do you
manage that? What's public and what's private?
>>Jack Stahl: It's a great question.
I was always a believer that the external
communication needed to be consistent with
the internal communication.
While we might not have been quite as specific,
we might have said, "OK, 600 drinks inside;
we wanna get there by the year 1999," as an
example.
With the three street, we would have said
over the next seven to ten years, we wanna
get to 600 drinks per person per year.
So, we were somewhat less specific so it didn't
turn into earnings guidance and quite as specific
as that, but we were pretty clear that this
is where we going and it was gonna drive our
strategies and behaviors at Coca-Cola.
So, it is a balance, 'cause you don't wanna
get over your tips with Wall Street, but at
the same time, people need to hear the same
stuff wherever they go in terms of where the
company was going. So, we tended to over communicate,
is the real answer.
Yes.
>>audience #9: I had a question where you
talk about a stretch in the organization.
Basically [ ]
>>Jack Stahl: Right.
>>audience #9: So your role is to sell more
of the same than you did [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Yeah.
Well, we did and we talked about other lines
of business that were in the refreshment business:
snacks, candies. Pepsi was in the snack food
business, for example.
But when we looked and did the analysis internally,
we saw that in our core strength, which was
beverages, at the core, carbonated beverages,
but then broadening, there was opportunities
if you broke the market down in bite-size
chunks.
And it said "let's stay close to home and
let's stay focused on what we can do best
and that's gonna carry us for another 15 years."
It was a conscious decision to stay a little
bit closer in.
[pause]
OK. And then, I'm sure a lot of you have seen
different models for thinking about how to
develop a plan.
This is just a simple framework that I have
found useful over a period of time.
If you're going to 600 drinks, what are the
assets that you have to work with? Well, you
have a great brand. You have customer relationships.
You've got a great employee base.
What are the action steps? Well, for us, it
was availability, affordability, acceptability.
Who has to do what? What were the barriers?
That's very important.
We realized we didn't have a great, new product
development department. We realized we didn't
have enough vending machines on the street.
We didn't have enough sales people calling
on stores across the United States.
Those were barriers we had to address in the
strategy. How can you overcome those barriers?
And sometimes they're simple.
At Revlon, we were trying to strengthen the
workforce and just by walking around the building
one day, I walked into the head of staffing
and I said, "Well, are we hiring good marketing
people?" And she said, "We can't." I said,
"What's the barrier?" She said, "Well, we
don't have enough good recruiting materials."
And I went back to my office and I made copies
of five different analysts’ reports who
said Revlon was gonna turn the company around,
and I said, "OK, here's some materials."
And just understanding the barriers that your
folks are facing and helping to try to solve
those problems as a leader can help get you
there.
And just listening to the challenges and the
problems.
And then finally, what do you expect to get
back in terms of financial and marketplace
results? So, overall, just a very basic strategy
model.
Any thoughts or comments in response to that?
OK.
[pause]
>>presenter: Jack?
>>Jack Stahl: Yes.
>>presenter: The folks in VC can't hear just
from the camera.
Can you talk in front of the mic, unfortunately?
>>Jack Stahl: OK, sure. OK, this goes back
to your question about communication.
[pause]
And can you all hear me? OK, great.
And communication is such an important part
of the process, and I like to say as a leader,
particularly in a change environment.
When things are broken, or you're trying to
build something for the first time, whatever
you think is required in terms of the amount
of communication you're doing, double it and
then double it again.
And there are enough math majors in the room
who can do that math and all of a sudden your
multiples, in terms of your communication
effort beyond what you thought was necessary
to move your organization, and it is just
the nature of people.
To your point earlier, how did you motivate
the organization?
When I went to Revlon, again, which was a
company in trouble -- not Google, a company
that's going from great to greater -- I made
it a point of every week, writing a letter
myself that went to five thousand people.
And then, every week I would get on a global
teleconference call and take any questions
in response to that letter about the progress
of the company, where Revlon was being successful
with retailers, our new products, where they
were working, where they weren't.
And just spend an inordinate amount of time
talking about the progress of our change pattern.
And as a leader, I think that's the kind of
effort that's required, particularly when
you're on a rapid growth curve, or you're
trying to change an overall environment.
And I would encourage you to think about your
own level of communication as leaders with
your team, with your customers, and is it
adequate for the environment that you're operating
in, and given the goals that you're trying
to achieve?
Any questions or comments about communication,
generally, or my point about what at least
I believe is required?
Yes.
>>audience #10: Did you ever go out on your
own after this and then just kind of spot
check and see if the average employee was
getting that message?
>>Jack Stahl: I did. And I'll make the point
in a moment, but I set a goal at Revlon to
try to have at least one hundred one-on-one
conversations a week.
[laughter]
And whether that was in the elevator, or in
the parking lot, and I'm not talking about
being part of a larger meeting, or even a
scheduled meeting, but at least a hundred
unscheduled conversations a week.
And if a work day is five days, it's 20 a
day.
And if it's stopping someone in the elevator
and saying, "OK, tell me what you do, what
challenges are you experiencing? Are there
things that you think I should be doing differently
as your leader?"
And that was one way of spot-checking to your
question about what messages were and weren't
getting through.
And it's amazing what didn't get through for
as much as we tried to communicate.
Yes.
>>audience #11: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Yeah, yeah. I found you almost
couldn't do too much.
And the problem is it takes, as a leader,
it takes a lot of energy.
Many of us are social people by nature and
some aren't. But even if you're a very social
person by nature, having a hundred conversations
a week just tires you out, believe it or not.
It can give you energy on one hand, and tire
you out. But I think most organizations that
are, if we said we're going to 600 at Coca-Cola,
or if at Revlon, we said we're gonna deliver
the promise of beauty and save the company
from bankruptcy, you couldn't over communicate.
It had to be part of what you did every single
day. 'Cause you would find people wouldn't
understand. Someone was writing that the company
was in trouble, or an analyst would say that
our new products and lipstick and cosmetics
weren't working. And you had to be constantly
reinforcing what was working and what wasn't
working.
[pause]
Any of you been in tough environments and
have seen the power of communication? Or any
examples that you all would want to provide
that might be useful? Anything that jumps
out where you've seen that work or not work?
[pause]
Yes.
>>audience #12: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Right.
>>audience #12: [inaudible] -- And just that
one communication from one person changed
the morale so much.
>>Jack Stahl: Right.
>>audience #12: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: That's great.
>>Jack Stahl: Terrific example.
Yes.
>>audience #13: I'm in [inaudible] and I am
constantly trying to look at a calendar trying
to figure out how to fit in every single meeting
that you're talking about communication with
all hands, sending e-mails, meeting people
in person, meeting with groups o f people
in person, doing all these things. And I guess
my question is, how do you fit it all in?
How do you know which method is the best method?
Is it better to do all hands? Is it better
to do all one-on-one? Really, what's going
to work the best? Because it doesn't seem
like there's going to be enough time to do
all of these things.
>>Jack Stahl: Right. OK.
Well, and I'm gonna speak to that in a minute
because I think begins to get to, as a leader,
how do you organize your own time and how
do you maximize your own effectiveness.
And part of it is, I think, the routines that
you set up for yourself. What do you look
at?
How frequently? A weekly meeting, a monthly
meeting, a routine report, and getting those
routines set up that cover the things that
are important to your business that are strategic.
If you get those routines set up properly,
it’s amazing how much time frees up for
you to be more flexible to communicate on
a broader fashion about what's happening in
your organization.
So, part of it is around organizing your time.
And I think part of it is just listening to
your organization, letting them give you feedback
for what tools are working or not as a communication
effort.
And sometimes, you have to adjust.
At Revlon, we did quarterly updates and we
got feedback that they didn't want to hear
from me. They wanted to hear success stories
from people that were actually making things
happen in different parts of the company.
I got off the stage. All I would do was introduce
two or three people and they would talk about
how they made a sales call that worked, or
they developed a new lipstick that sold like
crazy, or they developed a market in Asia,
and we shared success stories.
It gave people hope, but we were getting feedback
about the nature of our communication and
then we were adjusting constantly.
So, I think that helps to prioritize.
Yes.
>>audience #14: From sales, we sell a range
of products to people and I think each product
team here has a leader and those leaders communicate
to the sales team. So in that sense --
>>Jack Stahl: Right.
>>audience #14: [inaudible] Do you ever see
a situation like that happening [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Yeah. I've seen that often with
sales teams, because they've got external
pressures that are real--they're called customers.
And making sure that you're listening to your
sales leadership about what works for them
and what routines work for them and what don't,
I think is very important.
Because you want those people out selling
as opposed to necessarily only being focused
on internal communication.
So, I think it comes back to, again, a matter
of listening and just recognizing the importance
of that external pressure that that salesperson
is facing and making adjustments.
Did you have something in mind when you were
thinking about that?
>>audience #14: No. I think we're working
on ways to get those various teams in line
and streamline that communication. It's just
that it's hard to know which products are
going to be the right ones to push sometimes.
[inaudible] It's almost like setting up a
system where they all communicate together.
>>Jack Stahl: I think there's probably no
single solution that works and it is sometimes
just trial and error.
[pause]
And this comes back to your question about
how do you make it all work given the time
pressures.
And I am really a big believer in regularizing--that's
probably not a word-- but setting routines
around what it is we do as leaders.
And I'll give you an example.
At Revlon, when I went to the company, I would
walk around drug stores to see the cosmetics
products on displays in a Walgreens, or a
CVS, or wherever we were.
And it was obvious that the different functions
in the company were not talking to each other.
And I found myself having a series of one-off
meetings with sales, making sure they were
talking to marketing about what products were
coming out and operations, and my day was
becoming jammed with one-off meetings.
I finally set up, on Monday morning at 7:30,
a meeting with sales, new product development,
operations, finance, where we talked about
the new products that were coming out for
the next month, the next quarter, and over
the remainder of the year.
And who had responsibility for the product,
and what had to happen with sales and promotional
material for the product to make it to the
customer on time.
And only by setting up those regular meetings
did we get the right people in the room and
it tended to minimize the amount of problems
and crises that we were dealing with. Stuff
was happening real-time in the room, cross-functionally.
And so, being thoughtful about your control
systems, what you look at as a leader, the
information that you see, the meetings that
you participate in, all can I think buy you
time to have real impact on your organization.
[pause]
Any thoughts or comments, reactions to this
as you think about your own time in trying
to maximize your own impact?
[pause]
OK. Yes.
>>audience #15: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Yeah. Yeah.
I was in a business, the cosmetics business,
or the beauty business, new products are very,
very important.
At least 20 to 25 percent of your business
each year comes from products that weren't
on the shelf six months ago.
And you had to be fast in seeing a consumer
need, getting a product developed, whether
it be a face make-up, or a nail enamel, and
you had to be prepared to get it out the door
as fast as you could.
My experience was having the right routines,
while they can be boring and repetitive, if
you've got all the cross-functional people
in the room, make it up every week, and you're
looking each person in the eye; the salesperson,
OK, "what issues do you see? What are we missing?"
And you get problems surfaced early, and then
you can agree to follow up on that over the
course of the next week and take action and
then see if it happened.
If you can pull out from people what's causing
the issues, while it's tedious and time-consuming,
you're gonna pull months out of the new product
development process, for example.
And so, I think these control systems, or
management routines, are critical. I think,
to actually, speeding up time as opposed to
slowing it down, at least based on the businesses
that I've been a part of.
Excuse me.
Any other thoughts or questions on that one?
Comments?
OK. Execution. Leaders are sometimes taught,
well, they should operate at the strategic
level.
I think the best leaders that I've seen operate
at all levels, and they are very situational
in deciding where to spend their time and
energy.
I'm gonna give you an example.
At one point at Coca-Cola, I was responsible
for taking the company public and I had to
develop what's called an offering circular.
It's about a 300-page document that investors
read.
We were taking a bottling company public in
Canada. And you had to get this document done.
It describes the company, the financials,
the products, the system, and I was supposed
to get it done with the help of the lawyers,
the accountants, the tax people.
And I would call up the lawyers and say, "OK,
is your section done?" "Yeah, it's coming
along."
And I'd call up the tax people, "How's your
section coming? You got pages 32 through 60."
"Yeah, it's good. We'll be there."
And my boss came into the room one night.
He said, "Well, let's see your document."
And we had about 20 people sitting around
the table. And he gets to the first page of
the document, and mind you, we were taking
this company public; it's gonna be a new company
based in Canada, and he turns to the first
page and he says, "What's the phone number
for the new company?"
And I said, "The phone number." And I thought,
"Oh, I guess it is gonna need a phone."
And I said, "Well, we'll get that done the
day before we file."
And he said, "Well, why don't you do today
what you can do today? You're gonna have a
lot to do the day before you file this document
with the government."
And at that point, I had this flash of pain
in my mind, thinking, "Oh my God, he's gonna
go through the whole document like this."
And we did.
We were there till 2:30 in the morning. There
were 267 holes in the document like that,
starting with the phone number, the address,
certain financial data.
And it told me, as a leader, and I was leading
that project, that I need not assume good
execution by my teammates.
Now, when I saw it demonstrated by the lawyers,
for example, or the tax people, I wouldn't
have to worry about them.
But until I saw some evidence at ground level
that it was coming together, I was making
a big mistake. And I was convinced I was gonna
get fired.
And we sat there till three in the morning,
the guy took me home, he dropped me at my
house, I thought that was my last day and
he looked at me and said, "You'll catch up.
You're about two weeks behind, but you'll
catch up."
And he knew I was gonna experience that. He
just knew as a leader, I needed to learn the
lesson about the importance of focusing on
the details.
And I would just encourage you to think about
that. It's not just focusing strategically;
it is about knowing where to bore in and where
you can pull back.
And you have to be able to judge both.
Any comments on this one?
Yes, Alexander.
>>audience #16: I notice over the years that
there's a problem with the level of commitment
among our staff. People grow until they hit
their level and then they stay at the position
for a long time [inaudible]. In the spirit
you have just described…
>>Jack Stahl: Right.
>>audience #16: How do you impart that in
the organization? How do you keep people aligned
with their actual culpabilities?
>>Jack Stahl: I'm gonna speak to that in just
two clicks. It talks a little bit about people
development and it is thinking about how to
bundle those skills for people on a more systemic
basis. So if you'll allow me just a moment.
[pause]
Another element of the framework we've talked
about, so I'm not gonna belabor it, the importance
of being visible.
And I talked to you about a hundred one-on-one
conversations per week, and just setting a
target for being in touch with the people
at all levels of your organization, and across
the organization.
And setting yourself targets for doing that.
At Coca-Cola, when I was president of the
company, I kept a card in my pocket with the
company's hundred largest customers from around
the world.
And I knew if I didn't call, at least try,
to call three every day -- I would, because
my goal was to try to get to each of these
top one hundred customers about six times
a year on the telephone.
And I would just call and say, "What's happening?
How's Coca-Cola's service? How's the account
team servicing you? Anything I can do to be
helpful to you?"
It was a two-minute call. Sometimes, I'd learn
about something about their business where
we could create value for them, or a product.
And so, being visible to your people, to your
team members, to other functions, to your
customers, I think it's so important as a
leader, both learning and communicating what
you believe is important.
OK, what about developing people? And I think
this speaks to your question, Alexander.
I believe it's very important to demonstrate
to people that you, as a leader, particularly,
this is a hierarchical point to your question
earlier, that you have people management responsibility.
And I think to the extent that you can frame
up for your organization, and I understand
at Google, at some point you talk about universal
skills and you may or may not use that language
today, but what we tried to do at Coke was
develop something we called "core skills"
that are important across all functions, and
learning and questioning the environment around
you.
Do you read? Are you out in the world? Are
you seeing data that you can then use to connect
to something that's important to you on the
job?
And asking questions about what's possible.
At Coke, the question was, why do we sell
600 drinks per person per year in Mississippi,
but it's only 77 in California as a whole?
And asking those questions that can point
you to opportunities. That's a core skill
that I think is important in any environment,
whether you're coding, or whether or not you're
dealing with customers, or leading a marketing
operations team.
Another important skill is developing a plan.
We talked about a model to do that.
Focusing on the details is critical.
And how is that lesson learned, as an example?
I'll tell you how I learned it in addition
to the story that I told earlier.
At one point, I was Coca-Cola's Chief Financial
Officer and I was going off to Vienna, Austria,
to review business plans.
I got to Vienna; I was scheduled to be there
for a week. I had a long flight. I was looking
forward to having a great dinner, and I got
to Vienna and I unpacked my suitcase and I
had my shirts on the shelf and all my toilet
articles were stacked up and everything.
I was looking forward to a nice dinner with
my colleagues and I got a call on the phone
from the chairman of the company.
His name was Roberto Goizueta; very proper,
Cuban gentleman, actually. Ran the company
for about 20 years.
And he said, "Jack, I just got a financial
report about Spain and the numbers are wrong."
I said, "Roberto, it’s an internal company
report. I know there's an error. My team is
focused on it and I'll have an answer for
you when I get back a week from today."
And it was like he hadn't heard anything I
said. He said, "Jack. No, no, you don't understand.
What plane are you coming back to Atlanta
on tomorrow morning?"
And I said, "Roberto, I'm here for a series
of budget meetings and I'll be back a week
from today."
And he said, "And what plane did you say you
were on tomorrow morning?"
[laughter]
And I said, "Well, I think there's a nine
o'clock."
So, I calmly got my shirts down off the shelf
and my toilet articles, packed them into my
little suitcase, told my colleagues I wasn't
going to be having dinner with them after
all and got on the plane the next morning.
And he was reminding me about the importance
of detail, and getting it right, and getting
internal reports correct, or whether it was
that or calling on a customer, or a project
that you might be working on. I learned that
lesson forever.
I never wanted to have to repack my suitcase
and miss an important business trip, as an
example.
And I think just looking for ways to remind
people about that skill and these other skills
are critical.
It's constant reinforcement. It's constant
conversation with your people. It's asking
them about their challenges in these areas,
helping think through solutions. It's dialogue.
And I think with that, you've got a much better
shot at developing an organization with core
skills that they can use in any environment,
whether it be at Google or somewhere else.
And so, I think it's about conversation and
investing in your people. And people did it
for me and I learned and I make it a point
to do it with the people that I have responsibility
for.
So, I think the most important thing is, in
building organizational capability, is dialogue
and being clear about what counts.
Any reactions or thoughts to this one because
people development is so critical, particularly,
I would think, in an organization like this
one that's growing so fast and having capable
people to lead it, becomes increasingly critical.
Any thoughts or, yes.
>>audience #17: What would be your advice
for [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Yeah.
>>audience #17: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: I have this conversation a lot
with people because I'm involved in a bunch
of different organizations.
And my view is if your goal is to advance
in a business environment, let your focus
be one of skills orientation.
And a lot of people have an orientation, "Gee,
I wanna get exposure to different marketplaces,
or different parts of the business."
My view has always been decide what skills
are important and find an area where you can
learn these core skills, or those that might
work at Google, or somewhere else, and find
people that are willing to invest in you and
have conversations about where you're getting
it right and where you can do it better.
And then once you've learned these core skills,
you can take them anywhere.
At an early point in my career, before I had
learned many of these skills, I was at Coke
in Atlanta and the thought was "you should
go international" and I was asked to go move
to Germany to be like the assistant controller.
I was like, 26 or 27. That was a big job for
me when I was 26 or 27.
But the guy that I was working for in Atlanta
said, "Don't go to Germany. That person's
not gonna teach you those skills."
And I got five or six different jobs in Atlanta,
and I moved very well. I made more than my
share of mistakes. He let me do that, as I
indicated.
But I found I could take those skills out
of a financial environment and take them to
a general management role, running the US
business.
I'm convinced if I'd focused on something
different than the core skills, and focused
on just exposure, exposure to Germany or a
different business unit, I'd still be in Germany
today as the number two controller person
in Germany, which for me would have been a
missed opportunity.
So, for me, my experience and where I've seen
people move and create the most options is
decide what skills are important, who can
help me learn them, and stay where you get
the opportunities on projects, or different
roles to learn them, cause then it creates
options.
So, that's just one perspective on it.
[pause]
That really is the framework that I wanted
to share with you, from setting a destination
all the way through how to think about developing
your own people by setting a clear set of
expectations and investing in the dialogue
and conversation, but I really believe that
this framework can be applied in a lot of
different environments.
So, let me stop there and see if there are
any other questions that I could address,
or thoughts that you all would like to throw
out.
Yes.
>>audience #18: You mentioned ownership once.
Where does that fit in? In other words, assigning
or trying to make sure that people own the
things that are important [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Well, I think that notion of
ownership is, in a sense, something you can
hire against and you're looking at wherever
I've been, whether I've been at Coca-Cola
or at Revlon, you're looking for people that
really felt very strongly about the work that
they did, or the projects that they had been
responsible for in the past.
Could they give you examples of where they
really dug in and made things happen? Where
they focused on the details, where they set
a clear strategy and really felt like they
had the responsibility for the success or
failure of something.
And I think that attitude and looking for
it as you recruit and give people more responsibility
is, I think, critical. Because I think if
people have that, and they have a set of core
skills, that attitude, and those core skills,
I think chances are, they're gonna get off
to a reasonable start in most roles or most
environments.
Bright people will and you all are bright.
Yes.
>>audience #19: So I was just curious how
[inaudible] I'm sure you got all the time
offers to go other places to work. What [inaudible]
had you decide it was the right time to make
that move and why Revlon? Why did you go that
way? I'm sure you could find many other [inaudible]?
>>Jack Stahl: I felt, at Coca-Cola, I had
been part of a very big company and by the
time I left, the basic processes work.
We had a planning process. We had ways of
calling on customers, and it wasn't all perfect.
We made tons of mistakes, but all the basic
disciplines were pretty well defined.
And what I wanted to do at the next stage
of my career was do something that was a little
bit more entrepreneurial and operate in a
place that all that stuff wasn't working.
And I really wanted to see if I could help
create it and build it and help turn a company
around.
So, it was about that kind of challenge for
me.
It could have been in any industry. I just
happened to get a call about running a beauty
company, which seemed a little bit crazy and
I'm convinced at Coke, we always wore white
shirts and blue shirts, the only reason this
guy hired me was because that day, I had a
particularly colorful shirt on. Otherwise,
he would have said, "No, no. He's a boring
soft drink guy. He can stay there."
For me, it was about being more entrepreneurial
at that stage of my career than I had been
up until that point. I thought it would be
interesting for me.
>>presenter: We have time for one more.
>>Jack Stahl: OK. Yes.
>>audience #20: So most of the things you
[inaudible] were about business management
and leadership. Do you think all these methods
in terms of Google is [inaudible]? Do you
think if you had Coca-Cola based [inaudible]?
>>Jack Stahl: Well, I think when we made that
switch from high fructose corn syrup to sugar,
we viewed it as a very important part of the
formulation of Coca-Cola, but we did a tremendous
amount of research which said that both from
a health standpoint, a taste standpoint, even
a mouth feel standpoint, which is an important
part of a beverage, that the product was not
differentiable; you couldn't really tell the
difference.
And the economics of high fructose corn syrup
were much better than refined sugar and so,
we thought, "OK, if we can adopt a lower cost
sweetener for our products, it gives us more
money to reinvest in the brands and create
more growth." And so, I know that there's
some concerns today about HFCS--
>>audience #20: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: but from a taste standpoint,
there is no fundamental difference.
>>audience #20: [inaudible]
>>Jack Stahl: Yes.
>>audience #20: You can't tell the difference?
>>Jack Stahl: No. And I can, just having been
in a beverage company for so many years, I
can virtually smell the difference between
Coke and Pepsi, for example.
But I couldn't taste the difference between
sugar and high fructose corn syrup. I promise.
We could do it.
[laughter]
>>presenter: All right, well thank you very
much.
>>Jack Stahl: All right. Thank you.
[applause]